it's the budget carrier that soared from
a scrappy challenger brand to Europe's
largest airline but the success story of
dublin-based Ryanair's hit some
turbulence lately and today the human
cost of that became clear in an internal
video the company's chief executive
Michael O'Leary broke the news that
hundreds of jobs would have to go we
will need about 600 less pilots and
cabin crew for summer 2020 on top of
this bad news we already have a surplus
of over 500 pilots and some 400 cabin
crew because of resignations have dried
up to effectively zero since January of
2019 I'm sorry to advise you that this
means we need to cut our aircraft
numbers and our staffing not just for
summer 2020 but also in winter 2019
Ryanair boasts 153 million annual
customers and operates 2400 flights per
day but this week rhine air reported a
21 percent fall in quarterly profits
blaming lower fares and higher fuel and
staffing costs for the decline the
company's expansion plans had also been
hit by the grounding of the Boeing 737
max plane of which 58 have been ordered
by Ryan Air for summer 2020 Ryanair says
it simply cannot offer the number of
flights it was hoping to because of the
grounded Boeing 737 max aircraft after
two terrible tragedies claimed the lives
of 346 people they were due to have
dozens flying by now they won't get any
before next year and they say the rate
of expansion is simply going to have to
slow in September 2017 Reiner was forced
to cancel thousands of flights because
it hadn't allocated enough pilots now
less than two years later it says it had
hundreds of pilots to many a bad day for
Ryanair employees who won't know the
final details of the job cuts and base
closures for several weeks Stephen
Murphy Sky News in
mm